this is the world's first self-cleaning
Robot vacuum and mop the Frio sent To Us
by narwhal and it's completely changed
my life or at least the daily cleaning
routine at home now if you told me a
month ago that a little Robot vacuum and
mop could completely replace the level
of intricate and precise cleaning only a
person could do I wouldn't have believed
you but ever since we moved into our new
place and set up the Frio a month ago we
haven't actually had to vacuum or mop
our floors manually and that might be a
little hard to believe but but this
thing packs more than enough technology
to be able to live up to that claim but
before I dig deep into explaining all of
the features and why I've enjoyed this
thing so much let me give you a sneak
peek of a couple of the features that I
love about it first it has two large
water bins one for clean water and one
for dirty water both with sensors
that'll notify you when you need to
either fill up or empty a tank right
within the convenient app it has a touch
screen with a bunch of different modes
you can select including vacuuming and
mopping at the same time yes the same
time there's also the Frio mode which is
incredible because it can decide if it
needs to mop your floors again which
I'll explain how it works in just a
minute both the brushroll and mop pads
can automatically lift and push down
based on what it's cleaning and the last
little teaser is the incredible app
that's packed with customization but now
I've got to talk about what makes the
Narwhal Frio so special and it starts
with the design this thing looks
incredibly clean with this premium
looking finish and design that'll fit
right into any home anywhere you place
it I also love how the actual Frio robot
is tucked in while not in use so kids
won't trip over it like with other robot
vacuums the display is also really nice
with a very smooth UI that doesn't
glitch up and it's got a lot of settings
built in for adjustment even coming with
a child protection mode so kids won't be
able to come up and match the different
settings now on the inside of the base
station you can see the two tanks that
come with convenient handles and a
little plug on the clean tank for
filling it up and the dirty tank is
properly sealed so it doesn't smell but
my favorite part is the little slot on
the inside for narwhals Cleaning
Solution that's included in the box and
easy to install and this detergent
automatically gets mixed with the clean
water for better mopping leaving a fresh
scent and on the inside of the base
station you'll see the little charging
pads on the sides and you can easily
remove and clean both the white plastic
Pan and the cleaning tray which comes
with bumps that scrub against the mop
pads for self-cleaning which is what
makes it work so well as far as the Frio
itself it also looks great and unique
with a lidar scanner at the top which is
important because it's extremely
accurate in terms of scanning your room
and all the obstacles Furniture my
Island and everything else and because
it's lidar it ensures your privacy at
home and it works at night which is
important to me because I have mine
scheduled to run at 11 PM it's also jam
packed with a bunch of other sensors
including infrared ultrasonic obstacle
avoidance and time of flight for range
detection and if you flip open the lid
you'll see an easily removable extra
large 480 milliliter dust bin with a
built-in filter that you only have to
empty once a week even with daily
cleaning and it comes with a cool Little
Brush and hair cutter for the brush roll
now on the bottom we get a good look at
the Dual mop pads the wheels that can
intelligently lift up and down the brush
roll which is super easy to remove and
the spin brushes which help push debris
towards the brush row and now for the
fun part the actual cleaning when I
first tested out the Frio it scanned my
entire floor to create a map which you
can see within the app and then I had it
vacuum which was surprisingly clean and
effective since the Narwhal team
discovered that increasing the suction
power from 2500 to 5000 Pas only
improved dust pickup rate by two percent
so they run it at lower suction to keep
it nice and quiet but it still picks up
everything and then after that it mopped
the floors which was a cool process
because it first saturates the Mobs with
clean water and cleaning solution before
heading out to mop and the awesome part
is that every few minutes it stops lifts
the mop pads up comes back to the base
station to self-clean and scrub the mops
then drain the dirty water and then
saturate them once again with clean
water and heads out to the same spot to
continue mopping that right there is
amazing the whole process with scanning
vacuuming and mopping took about two and
a half hours and I was surprised to see
the battery life was still at over 60
percent which blew my mind and when it's
done it'll go into self-drying mode to
make sure it dries the mop pads to stop
mildew growth or any bad smells and then
I discovered my favorite mode of all
vacuum and mop mode which does both at
the same time so as you can see the Frio
Vacuums in the front while the mops are
mopping in the back finishing both tasks
in one go and the whole floor was
cleaned in just 45 minutes and it
honestly does a great job at mopping
since the mop pads push down as they
spin and you can see how wet the floors
get as well and using the Frio mode
it'll actually detect if it needs to
come back and mop Again by analyzing the
dirty water as it drains which is
incredible and speaking of the dirty
water check out how dirty it is when
emptying the dirty water tank that's how
you know it's effectively mopping your
floors and even better the mop pads are
easily removable if you want to give
them a quick wash but the self-cleaning
works so well that after a month I still
haven't needed to do that another cool
thing about the Frio is that it can
actually apply pressure while vacuuming
your carpets or rugs to make sure it
really digs in and gets rid of dust
instead of just glazing over them and
now finally I've got to talk about the
app because it's got some really cool
features when you open it you get a full
view of your floor which you can zoom
into and as you can see the Frio
automatically detected the carpet and
rug areas as you can see shaded in blue
and the gray areas are my couches
furniture and my Island this little
shaded red area is a no-go Zone known
that I created myself which is a cool
feature and then on the bottom you have
a start button and all of your modes
which you can customize by tapping this
button and adjusting the number of times
you want it to clean the suction power
for vacuuming and the level of wetness
for the mops but my favorite is the area
button at the top where you can set a
customized area for spot cleaning and
you can make it larger so you can clean
areas like just your dining room and
then finally there's a bunch of settings
you can customize like stairless mode
drying intensity and Corner Cleaning
frequency but the most useful thing to
me was to set up a customized plan on a
schedule so every two days it'll vacuum
at 11 PM and on the opposite two days
it'll vacuum and mop which is my
preferred schedule and honestly after a
month of using the Frio we literally
haven't had to mop our floors ourselves
not even once the Narwhal just does it
for us and it keeps the floors super
clean while I can sit back and relax on
the couch and that right there is
priceless so with that said I've got to
thank narwhal for sending us this review
unit because I don't think I can go back
to manual mopping my floors ever again
and if you're interested in checking out
the Frio you can check it out using the
links in the description below thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video